the pinocchio fables been teaching and
terrifying children since the 18th
century but the 2022 disney live-action
retelling offers inside jokes easter
eggs and even some innuendo for the
adults who pay attention
the pg-rated pinocchio features a couple
of clever almost but not quite swear
words it also features a very adult
comment about human sexuality that's so
subtle and meandering that only older
viewers listening closely would even
notice jiminy cricket is the tool
through which the filmmakers answer the
perpetual burning question at the center
of the pinocchio story if geppetto wants
to make a child so badly why does he
think making a puppet out of wood and
then aggressively wishing for it to come
to life is the fastest and most
effective way to make that happen jiminy
cricket explains it away with a joke
laden with shade and double entendre
when faced with the question jiminy
cricket remarks well sure there are
other ways to make a boy but i don't
think gepetto gets out much and i guess
it's the best he could do with the tools
he's got ouch
one of the most memorable moments in
disney's classic 1940 animated version
of pinocchio was the pleasure island
sequence while undoubtedly terrifying to
younger viewers the depiction of the
consequences of a visit to the kitty
chaotic dream world of fun and
misadventure had to be included in the
live-action remake and it's a true
spectacle a dazzling fireworks laden
display of amusement park rides petty
crime debauchery and tomfoolery kids can
eat all the junk they want shoplift
break stuff and cheat death only to
learn later that admission wasn't free
after all there is a steep price to be
paid while the idea of no such thing as
a free lunch or every action has
ramifications are lessons far more
familiar to adults than they are to
children older viewers may also find
themselves at odds with the entire
conceit of pleasure island after
engaging in the delights of the park
pinocchio and his new friend lampwick
are transformed into donkeys it's all
part of a nefarious plan by the parks
organizers they lure in wayward youth
and let them have all the fun they want
after a good time the park's dark magic
transforms the kids into donkeys that
are then sold off when you think about
it the enormous expense level of detail
and work required to create and maintain
pleasure island doesn't seem worth the
investment just to turn kids into
adorable but cheap pack animals
most any film adaptation of pinocchio
including disney's live action 2022
version is meant for an audience of
children as it's based on a 19th century
children's book and it's about a child
but pinocchio also deals in some pretty
heady concepts ones that are beyond most
children and all but the most thoughtful
and philosophically minded of adults the
pinocchio fable and the 2022 take in
particular is an exploration of ethics
and what it means to be human it asks if
ethics are indeed what separates people
from other animals or inanimate objects
like a wooden boy for all intents and
purposes pinocchio is made a real-life
boy just after geppetto builds him
thanks to some magic from the blue fairy
however while he's technically a human
pinocchio is made to think that this
status is provisional that he won't
really be real until he's lived a little
bit and you have to prove that you are
brave
truthful and unselfish in other words he
has to prove his humanity and understand
it before he can claim it at the end of
the film pinocchio is still made of wood
but he's learned those lessons and is
thus declared a real person the 2022
disney produced live action pinocchio
earned a pg rating meaning that it's
friendly to family isn't palatable to
all but the youngest of children who
might take issue with some of the more
frightening and distressing moments of
the film when pinocchio or gepetto find
themselves in extreme danger that peachy
rating is also a short way of saying
there are no bad words in this movie
this isn't to say however that the
screenwriters weren't totally able to
get around disney's cleanliness mandate
and a desire for a very mild rating from
the mpaa they inserted some bits that
work as wordplay but which really
subvert the pg rating to get in a couple
of adults-only phrases jiminy cricket
the external and appointed conscience of
pinocchio is similarly the conscious of
the audience it's surrogate in the crazy
fantasy world of the film he openly
questions the proceedings often at one
point rhetorically asking what the cuss
is that all about instead of saying a
cuss word he just says the word cuss as
if it were a cuss word an effective
profanity replacement lifted from wes
anderson's pg and urbane fantastic mr
fox
the cuss you are
the casamay
are you cussing with me no you cussing
with me then after lampwick turns into a
donkey but is not yet aware he's a
donkey he aggressively asks pinocchio
what do i look like to you
a jackass
he means literally and that a jackass is
another name for a donkey but it works
on the other metaphorical slightly
profane level too
over a lifetime of consuming media older
viewers are conditioned to react
emotionally to narrative storytelling
the 2022 version of pinocchio spins its
first third connected to chipetto
sympathizing with and pitying the lonely
old man who just wants to know the joys
of fatherhood viewers then celebrate
along with him when his marionette
pinocchio comes to life
but there is an abrupt disconnect when
almost immediately after fulfilling his
ageless wish to be a dad geppetto
seemingly washes his hands of it all
[Music]
maybe it is time for you to go to school
after pinocchio comes to life in the
middle of the night and geppetto
celebrates his magical birth he coldly
tells him to go to school the very next
morning he gives him some school
supplies and opens the door he shows him
the general direction in which he needs
to go what time he expects him home that
afternoon and sends him on his way
geppetto shifts from warm to cold so
fast that it's baffling he doesn't even
walk pinocchio to school or let the
teacher know they'll have a new student
he could at least spend some time with
the new son he so desperately wanted
in the 2022 pinocchio the blue fairy
played by cynthia arrivo tells pinocchio
that while she has technically turned
him human with her magic he's not really
a human until he understands what that
means he needs to live a little and
build a code of ethics around being
brave truthful and unselfish that's all
well and good but older pinocchio
watchers will notice that pinocchio's
not at all prepared to go out in the
world and learn anything pinocchio is a
blank slate
i'm the blue fairy i'm the blue fairy no
i'm the blue fairy no i'm the blue fairy
before he sets off for school and
unsurprisingly winds up having a series
of horrible and mere deadly
misadventures pinocchio has only been
alive for a few hours he has no inner
life no frame of reference no background
and no memories he deals with the world
as it comes to him so he's bound to make
a few mistakes
i don't want to be a jerk i want to be a
real boy
for example he's overly trusting of
shady strangers like so-called honest
john and he doesn't pick up on clues
that danger is around the corner as with
pleasure island then he's chided
chastised and punished for allowing
himself to fall into so many moral and
physical traps ones he didn't even know
existed pinocchio lets others take
advantage of him but how could he avoid
it under the circumstances
in the 2022 pinocchio jiminy cricket is
a complicated dark figure with what
seems to be a sketchy past jiminy
cricket bug boulevard gate lander man
leisure he opens the film by singing the
classic when you wish upon a star from
the 1940 animated pinocchio but 21st
century gemini delivers the song with a
rye wink he knows he and his song are
known all over the world he goes on to
explain that he's in the now telling the
story of pinocchio and geppetto as if it
happened in the distant past
some storyteller you are
seeing is how pinocchio takes place in
the 1800s this makes gemini well over
200 years old he's lived a long life
with many chapters including the one
where he drifted into an italian village
and got a job from a blue fairy she
appoints him pinocchio's conscience due
to proximity more than any sort of moral
authority if anything he's a risky
choice as the story's ethical compass
i'm not a conscience i'm a cricket more
of an insect than an instinct this
cricket might be kind of a weirdo at the
mention of geppetto's selling of
oddments he saw silly quips
sounds like my kind of place
in other words this cricket is a little
sus
the blue fairy assumes jiminy cricket
knows how to be the boy's conscience
whether he does or not he never provides
much guidance or assistance other than
vague worry when he even bothers to hang
around that is he offers platitudes
about life in the form of sarcastic
observations about the events of the
movie as they unfold these gags are less
for his wood in charge than for the
audience attentive older viewers will
hear the social commentary between
gemini's lines for a movie made by
entertainment behemoth disney the sassy
cricket's comments have a distinct
anti-hollywood bent after hearing
pinocchio excitedly tell him about his
honest john purportedly a talent agent
who can make the kid famous jiminy
observes honest john pinocks as a rule
of thumb when somebody calls themselves
honest
they ain't especially if they're an
agent honest john dishes out plenty of
anti-corporate sentiment himself he
remarks that pinocchio won't have to
worry about much of anything when he's
famous particularly taxes and then
there's the hollywood n joke in the
scene where honest john and pinocchio
meet he only entertains the notion of
being an actor because jiminy cricket
his conscience isn't around to tell him
it's a bad idea
the natures and abilities of animals in
2022's pinocchio remake may puzzle older
viewers should they think too hard about
it the rules of the world in which the
movie is set are inconsistent with
regard to who can think and speak and
who can't there's obviously a
supernatural element at play as
pinocchio is transformed from inanimate
to walking and talking wood through the
actions of a cynthia a vero sized fairy
but there's no explanation for why some
animals talk while others just meow
jiminy cricket is a bug who speaks and
is so trusted that he's tasked with
serving as a conscience honest john is a
fox the size of a small person he talks
but he's nasty and immoral sofia the
seagull speaks but only to other animals
while geppetto's two pets tagaro the cat
and cleo the goldfish never pipe up
maybe pets don't talk and wild
independent animals do except monstro
the whale that swallows gepetto
pinocchio and the pets never utters a
word
lots of big franchise type family movies
are seated with references to familiar
pop culture artifacts of the past the
2022 live action remake of disney's
pinocchio is no exception offering
plenty of easter eggs to viewers who pay
close attention an establishing shot of
geppetto's workshop shows the audience a
wall hung with dozens of clocks of the
cuckoo novelty noisy and mechanical
varieties while they're only visible for
a few frames many of those timepieces
are disney branded items among the
classic characters that make an
appearance on geppetto's clocks are
princess aurora from sleeping beauty
donald duck woody from toy story and
roger and jessica rabbit from the disney
adjacent who framed roger rabbit the
director of the latter happens to be
robert zemeckis who coincidentally
happens to have directed this very
pinocchio movie he also co-wrote and
helmed the 1985 sci-fi comedy back to
the future this wall of clocks sure
feels like a reference to zemeckis's
breakthrough film the iconic time travel
movie opens with the camera taking in a
bunch of time-telling devices
[Music]